in the 21 years since author JK Rowling
published the first entry into what
would become the wildly successful Harry
Potter book series fans have concocted
some pretty far-out theories there was
the infamous one from 2004 that argued
the freckled-faced Ron Weasley was
actually Albus Dumbledore travelling
back in time there was the suggestion
that Professor Minerva McGonagall wasn't
the trustworthy kind and wise head of
Gryffindor everyone knew her ass but was
actually a Death Eater there was even a
reddit fan theory that claimed Jenny
Weasley made love potions in the sixth
book Harry Potter and the half-blood
Prince and used them to induce Harry's
feelings of intense infatuation for her
while rolling hasn't been shy about
addressing fan theories in the past
there's one she hasn't touched on until
now and it's one Harry Potter fans have
long suspected to be true these days
everyone knows how to pronounce the name
of Hogwarts feistiest little wizard come
on e but before 2000 it wasn't exactly
common knowledge on Twitter one user
theorized that Rowling included the
passage about how to properly pronounce
Hermione Granger's name in the fourth
book Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
just to school all of us who were saying
her my own like Viktor Krum
after Viktor repeatedly refers to her as
her my own Hermione clarifies that her
name is actually pronounced Hermione
but should I said that I should not have
said that I should have said when Harry
Potter fans first read the Goblet of
Fire back when it was originally
published in 2000 they probably took the
scene as little more than a slightly
awkward but mostly chuckle worthy moment
between the incredibly intelligent
Hermione and Viktor as time went on
however more and more readers started to
believe that the conversation had a
double meaning and served to subtly
inform fans on how to say Hermione's
name the correct way once Rowling caught
wind of the theory she simply responded
theory correct sure the theory isn't as
bizarre as the ones we mentioned before
but it's long but unpopular one amongst
Potterheads and it's a good thing that
Rowling tossed the small moment into the
Goblet of Fire since it appears that
countless Harry Potter fans were saying
Hermione's name all wrong until she gave
Victor a pronunciation lesson the
Twitter account for the fansite
Wizarding news
did after rolling confirmed the theory
I'm embarrassed that took three and a
half books to learn that pronunciation
like many others I had never seen the
name Hermione before my life definitely
pronounced it her me own in my head for
far too long don't you to read another
Twitter user shared that she didn't even
know Hermione's name was Hermione
because her parents couldn't pronounce
the character's name when reading her
the book at bedtime
the most prominent memory I have of my
parents reading Harry Potter to me
before bed is my Dad going while that's
a stupid name from now on I'm gonna call
her Jane soon when this will face the
choice between what is right and what is
easy thankfully a year after Victor got
all tongue-tied in the Goblet of Fire
which was published in 2000 fans got to
hear Emma Watson say Hermione Granger's
name in the first Harry Potter movie
ever since there haven't been many
mispronunciations I'm Heidi Granger and
you are wrong Leslie pleasure
[Music]